[Applause]
[Music]
I love India Sydney because it's such a
great variety of people of topics of
content because I can come here and not
get jetlag the NBC conferences are some
of my favorite in the world it's really
amazing how much they've expanded they
put on an amazing event it's probably
one of the biggest conferences in
Australia at the moment it's just a
melting pot of different technologies
and ideas all sorts of different
frameworks and stacks we don't have a
whole lot of conferences in Australia
it's a long way for us to go anywhere
else
so being able to have a big event like
this in the biggest city in the country
that everyone can get to pretty easily
is absolutely very different conferences
that target specific space but it's the
only one that does a bit of everything
having a having an event fits of the
quality of NDC this is right around the
corner for me it's just invaluable great
melting pot of all developers from not
just around the city not just around
Australia but around the entire region
and perhaps even around the world it's
been great to see plenty of diversity in
our submissions and we've put together a
really well-rounded agenda we look
forward to another fantastic and
assisted me I can't wait to see you all
there
[Music]